70 jahre berlinale
das sollte ein großes fest werden ein
jubiläums akt nicht einmal 24 stunden
nach dem schrecklichen attacken in hanau
war das nicht möglich
es war eine sehr schwierige aufgabe für
den neuen moderator samuel finzi einen
weg zu finden worte zu äußern
zur gegenwärtigen bewusstseinslage und
gleichzeitig den film ins zentrum zu
stellen und vorzustellen und zu feiern
man kann sagen er ist gründlich
gescheitert mit diesem versuch man kann
ihm vielleicht keinen großen vorwurf
machen aber es war die falsche
performance die er gemacht hat es waren
die falschen witze es waren die falschen
leichtfertigen versuche sich selbst eine
eigene geschichte
die grundsätzlichen politischen fragen
der zeit und so weiter zu verbinden mit
dem was in hanau passiert ist er wurde
unterbrochen von zwischenrufen die nach
einer schweigeminute verlangten die
atmosphäre war bedrückend und man muss
wirklich sagen dass erst als die
kulturministerin grütters und auch der
regierende bürgermeister michael müller
hier ans mikrofon traten und die
richtigen worte fanden einen moment von
von von verantwortung im raum lagen
der eröffnungsfilm der dann gezeigt
wurde
das kann man ihnen nicht zum vorwurf
machen aber man muss es einfach sagen es
war der falsche film zum falschen
zeitpunkt eine szenerie die burg
einen eigenen gegen premier league sehr
positiv aber ein film meisterliga hier
der in rudy allen haffter nonchalance
new york umkreist bilder generiert
sprache findet die gute und unterhaltsam
ist aber die keinerlei wirklichen
eindruck hinterlässt oder ein umtreibt
man muss allerdings sagen dass eine
wunderbare sigourney weaver die man hier
als leiterin dieser literaturagentur
noch mal bewundern kann mit einer
unglaublichen grandezza mit einer mit
einer kühle die aber von innen her
brodelt für sie lohnt sich der film muss
als zuschauer als ein bewegter
kinogänger natürlich auch auf seinem
gefühl hören und in einer ganz
bestimmten weise sagen dass das nicht
der film war die man heute abend
gebraucht hat